my name is Matt Herman I am a data
scientist at the Council of State
government's Justice Center we are a
nonprofit uh research and policy
organization working on criminal justice
issues um and I think for folks that are
here today um not to see Jenny and
Hadley's travel pictures which were
lovely but maybe you saw the um subtitle
of my talk and you're really interested
in this cool new getrich quick
multi-level marketing scheme so I'm just
going to jump straight to that part of
the story here and introduce you first
to Kyle Walker um Kyle is a geography
professor and he's also the developer of
a number of great R and python packages
including the Tidy sensus package and in
2019 he sent me this direct message on
Twitter he says hey Matt do you do any
Consulting I received a tidy sensus
Consulting request but I'm book solid
let me know if you're
interested so I got this message I got
really really excited um played it super
cool and waited three hours to
respond and I said hey Kyle haven't done
much Consulting but definitely
interested um and Kyle said sounds good
I'm passed along your email address so
uh for I think a lot of people getting a
message like this or a conversation like
this might be sort of normal not that
out of the ordinary but for me it it was
really surprising I didn't feel like
Consulting material at that Point um
when I was an undergraduate I never took
any technical classes no computer
science I mostly hung out at my College
radio
station um after college I ended up
working in public radio and then I made
my way into the food business I helped
my friend open a butcher shop that was
called ends meet get it um and then
eventually ended up in graduate school
um for
sociology but I did have one thing going
for me here is and that's that I really
knew the Tidy sensus package and how to
use it really really well um for folks
in the room who aren't familiar with
tidy sensus it's a really cool r package
that lets you get data from the US
Census Bureau directly into your R
session via web API and so this makes it
really easy to do all sorts of neat
stuff like make a map of household
income by census trct in Chicago and to
make this map you really just need a few
lines of Tidy sensus and ggplot to code
so that first code chunk is pulling that
data and also the geometries from the
Census API into your R session and then
couple lines of ggplot 2 code to make
this beautiful
map um but my talk today really is not
about how to use tidy census and it's
not about Twitter it's not about
Consulting it's more about how I went
from working in a butcher shop to
getting Consulting gigs um to being able
to speak to you today at this conference
and um what I'm going to argue today in
this conference is that really
anyone who knows how to write code for
data analysis or data visualization in R
can and probably already should like can
and should become a package developer
too or at least a package contributor
and I think you already have the tools
to do
this this is my daughter Tessy um she's
two and she's really into water and
really wanted to learn how to swim this
summer um so we're good parents so we
didn't just pick her up and drop her off
into the deepest body of water we could
find and see if she floated we didn't do
that um we brought her to this beautiful
Lake where we live in Vermont and let
her explore you know walk into the water
get wet Splash around see how it
feels um and so if you are ready for
your our packaged development journey I
do not recommend going and finding a
very high diving board in jumping in the
deep end please don't start by
submitting a package to cray um that's
not going to be fun in the same way that
I don't think we should drop Tessy into
the deep end of a
pool um so one good way I think that you
can start is with GitHub issues um I
think most folks in the room are
probably familiar with GitHub it's a
place where a lot of our packages are
stored um issues are a really really
wonderful place to ask a question about
an art package or maybe you found a bug
in aack package you used or maybe
there's a feature you'd like to request
and you can just post that up on GitHub
and it's a really good place to start
and in fact for me that is my and was my
first contribution to the Tidy census
package um I was in graduate school
doing a lot of work and research using
census data and I discovered R
discovered tidy census I liked using
that much better than the census website
and I was hooked right away um so this
is actually my first
contribution to tidy census is an issue
I opened July 2017 and I say I just
started exploring tidy census today and
I love it uh one question is there a way
to get one year versus five-year
estimates details here are not important
but then I go on to write as much more
of an R user than a programmer I can't
help with actually implementing this
feature but I certainly would use this
few weeks go by the alfor mentioned Kyle
Walker says this functionality is Now
supported um so this is aming for a lot
of reasons first we have a document of
the day I started using tidy census
which is apparently July 17th 2017 great
day um but also uh so I had this idea I
knew about census data and I wanted to
get a different kind of census data that
wasn't currently available in tidy
census um and then all of a sudden a few
weeks later the package developer Kyle
made some changes to the package and now
I could get this data so I was super
stoked um uh also any other user of Tidy
census are also could sort of take
advantage of this and now they can get
this great data and for Kyle as a
package walker uh for Kyle as a package
developer he was getting direct user
feedback maybe he hadn't thought that
users might want to specify one year
versus fiveyear data so this got me
really excited about R about tidy sensus
and about GitHub and package development
and so I continued on following the Tidy
sensus GitHub repository paying
attention to the issues learning more
about package and how things worked um
and what I ended up doing is actually
starting to respond to GitHub issues so
this is from a few months later um
GitHub user big ck2 it's very cool
username um asked a question about
getting fiveyear data from
2016 and I happen to know the answer to
this question and I write here oh yeah
you can do this but you got to install
the dev version from GitHub uh big ck2
says great I downloaded the dev version
and it works great thank you um so this
is really great for a lot of reasons too
one big ck2 gets the answer to his
question now he can get the data second
if someone else has this exact same
issue hopefully they find this GitHub
issue and they know oh I just have to
install the devb
version and third Kyle the main package
developer and maintainer didn't have to
do anything here he can spend his time
writing our code not responding to
GitHub issues but I as a sensus user
Enthusiast could help out big
ck2 um and I continued on this sort of
path learning more about the package
responding to more GitHub issues and I
sort of have direct evidence here of
Kyle appreciating this so uh at some
point in some other GitHub issue that we
were talking about uh Kyle says MF
Herman that was me you're the best I'm
putting you down as a package
contributor on the next cray release for
answering so many user questions so this
is really exciting to me again didn't
see myself still don't really see myself
as a programmer or coder but now um I'm
a co-author or contributor to this
awesome package that I love to
use um so let's say you're ready to get
a little bit deeper into the water um
you're starting with the doggy paddle
you're maybe going up to your neck a
little bit and you want to actually
start contributing some code to a
package um I think bug fixes simple bug
fixes are a really great place to start
um along this journey maybe you also are
reading the art packages book uh you're
understanding a little bit more about
Dev tools and you kind of want to apply
some of these things you're learning
about into a package that you like to
use and this is exactly what I did um so
this is I don't know and looks like
December
2018 uh I noticed a bug that was related
to an update to tibble um that was
causing some Downstream issues in tidy
census not a really big deal um but it
it was a bug and it needed to be taken
care of and so I hunted around in the
code I I remember it really took a
really long time to figure out where
this um bug was occurring I didn't
really know I didn't have that whole
workflow the beautiful like load all
check test all that stuff I I didn't
really understand it was a lot of manual
hunting but I tracked down this bug and
I thought that was really cool I figured
out how to make it work on my computer
um and then I made this poll request on
GitHub um also note this poll request is
Tiny like 11 lines of code really really
small but again this is another example
um this was an issue that genuinely had
to be fixed when tibble was going to be
updated and this is something that again
Kyle um with limited amount of time to
devote to resources didn't have to do he
looked at my code uh it worked and he
was able to merge so this is a really
great way to contribute and to get your
feet wet a little bit more again 11
lines of
code I think a Next Step that might be
if you want to sort of keep going on
this path and this is what I did here is
think about a small feature that you
might want to add to the package nothing
big no you know not not whole new
functions or anything like that um for
me there was a a sort of convenience
function an additional argument that I
wanted to add to one of the core tidy uh
core tidy sensus packages core tidy
sensus functions that I thought would
make a user's life a little bit easier
and I had this idea I figured out how to
code it up seemed like it was working
and again PLL request it got merged
again 101 lines of code added not a
really big um sort of addition to the
package in the grand scheme of things
but this was for me a really exciting
moment because what this meant was there
was a new argument in the get ACS
function and so not only could I use
that because it was useful for me but
anyone else who installed this package
from GitHub or cran now had access to
that function and so that meant that
like my code lived on tens or hundreds
or thousands of people's computers and
again that to me uh was a really good
feeling and it made me feel more like
this package developer not just that R
user that I started
as um a third way that I think you can
really uh make a lot of impact on your
package contributions is by taking your
domain knowledge the thing that you know
better than anyone else and figure out a
way to encode that into an r package and
code that into somehow our functions or
documentation I've always really loved
this quote from Zed Shaw he says
programming as a profession is only
moderately interesting you're much
better off using Code as your secret
weapon in another
profession um and this is exactly how I
felt you know I I was coming at this I
was studying sociology and other sorts
of social
research I I was never going to be a
professional programmer but I did know a
lot about s Census Data I did know a lot
about other kinds of social research and
so the idea here is that that was my
secret weapon right I I I couldn't write
the most amazing R code in the world but
was there some way that I could take
what I knew about the census and what I
knew about um sociology and put that in
to the r package somehow and so this is
exactly what Kyle and I worked on next
and this was actually a big new feature
it allowed users to get census micro dat
um so instead of summarized data where
you just say a count of how many people
live in a certain area you could
actually get individual lines of data
that represented responses to the
American Community survey directly into
your R session so this is really neat um
and along with this uh I worked on a
package vignette um vignette is
essentially documentation an article
about how to use your package um so this
is the vignette called working with
census micro dat that you can find on
the Tidy census website right now and I
do want to just point out the table of
contents here so if you look at some of
these things um talking about Puma's
public use micro dat area uh person
level data housing level data uh how to
calculate standard errors none of this
is about our code none of this is about
R programming this is about the stuff
that I know
about census data and it's in an r
package so this is again providing huge
value and getting all that domain
knowledge out of my head and into an R
package through documentation so that
users who might be interested in this
also can benefit from it um around this
time Kyle sent me another Twitter DM he
says changed your role on package to
co-author and this didn't really mean
much to anybody but you know now my name
is on the Tidy sensus website and again
this is another sort of point of
validation for me and it it felt really
good to be a co-author of this
package um so what what I hope to sort
of get across here is that there's a lot
to different ways to contribute to
packages and I think this map of sort of
how I did it starting with GitHub issues
just asking them then maybe responding
to GitHub issues that you see maybe
level up and get into fixing little bugs
or adding small new features and then
eventually taking what you know outside
of our package development and try to
insert it into the package framework is
like a really powerful and there's a lot
of good reasons for why I think everyone
who's an R user might want to do this
and I think of them along sort of two
Dimensions here the first is becoming a
tool Builder so you're going to improve
your R programming skills marketly when
you start thinking about writing
functions you're learning about
abstracting your code and writing
modular and generalizable code you're
going to learn all about unit tests um
and how important those are you're also
going to learn a lot about git and
GitHub maybe if you're a solo R user you
might use git just for Version Control
on your own but once you're in the
package development world you're all
about collaboration and so you're going
to learn really quick about forks and
clones and merge requests and merge
conflicts and all that fun GitHub stuff
and I think ultimately what this does is
make you more desirable to an employer
because you can say not only do I know
how to use R I'm also an r package
developer um also I know how to use git
and GitHub really well um the other
domain that I kind of think of this on
is on community
contributions so you through this are
going to be able to meet other R users
online
I've never actually met Kyle in person
but as you can see we've communicated a
lot on Twitter on GitHub and other
places and I kind of think of him as a
friend you're also going to be able to
grow and sustain the open source
community so as our users we all are
have benefited so much from so many
people who have volunteered their time
to contribute to the open source
community and so me now as a tidy sensus
co-author I'm able to give back in just
a little bit a little way um and show my
appreciation for that community and help
grow it and help sustain it and then you
might get really cool opportunities like
being able to stand up on the stage and
speak to you at positon um and sort of
interestingly enough here there is some
documentation of this uh I I wrote this
Twitter message to Kyle I said hey I've
been toying with the idea of submitting
a talk proposal I doubt it'll get
accepted but just wanted to make sure it
was cool with you and Kyle says yeah of
course go for it um I do want to note
here I sent this to him in August of
2020 and I was talking about our studio
comp 2021 um life got in the way there
was a global pandemic my daughter Tessy
was born didn't end up submitting it
then um but I what I really think um
that I learned from this whole journey
is that it's never too early in your R
programming to Career to start
contributing to our packages and there's
lots of different ways to do it um also
apparently it's never too late to apply
to speak at
positon thank
you thanks Matt that was great yeah um
we do have a little bit of time for
questions if you want to ask one or two
anyone from the audience there's not on
slido right now but if you do have a
question I can come to you m with the
microphone I was curious to know um so
you've contributed a lot to tidy census
now like now that you've done all that
do you feel more comfortable
contributing to other packages and have
you done any contributions to other
packages um that's a great question I
mostly i' I've started building a lot of
internal packages at work um I I do
contribute to a few other packages like
tigress and sort of in the spatial
universe but really it gave me the
confidence to just like go build a bunch
of packages um at work to make my life
easier so yeah which I think everyone
should do I guess you learn those skills
through working on Tidy senses right%
you know it's like it demystified it and
I think gave you a place to start and
you know when I was doing this this was
before like use this and Dev tools were
as userfriendly as they are now um and
so getting started was kind of
intimidating but so starting through
this process showed me kind of how all
the pieces fit together and then when I
wanted to make an internal one it's
ready to go great thank you so much
[Applause]
Matt